Are tech companies suppressing information about abortion online?
This article in the New York Times makes a pretty compelling argument
why yes,
they probably are.
Reproductive health service providers like hey Jane,
Mayday Health, and Aid Access.
We're all talking about how social media and big search engines
are limiting their information online.
Exhibit A hey Jane has been limited or restricted
or suspended on TikTok four times in the last year.
Instagram also suspended Mayday Health account twice in 2022.
One of the suspensions literally lasted five days.
Let's not forget that the at feminist account was also
suspended recently
for 6 days. Hmm.
This doesn't account for all the different times that
post have probably been removed.
That talk about the big A word.
What's also wild is that even to say the word abortion on this video,
I'm probably gonna be restricted.
And it's not just social media
being has literally suppressed information from Aid Access.
A super vital healthcare provider
that shares and sends abortion pills all around the world
cannot advertise on their platforms.
Amnesty International is asking that these big tech platforms
like TikTok, Instagram,
Bing, Google,
all of them just share more information.
why is information about abortion suppressed and how do we avoid it?
How do we make sure people can get the accurate information they need?
If Amnesty International is involved,
it's clearly a human rights issue.
Everyone has the right to free accessible abortion information,
reproductive health care information,
and It shouldn't be suppressed
in a place where most people are getting information
about their bodies.
What do you think?
Have you experienced this before?
Tell us in the comments.